mike mike calls him numbers ellie what
you got what you got for us man what
stats you got for that's what life is
like
life is about numbers just name it you
got a birthday in your death date and
then between your phone numbers your
inmate numbers
everything's a number times a number
it's all a number i said mike we got the
encyclopedia here ellie what you got
what you got
numbers that's numbers hey hey numbers
numbers
call pastel somebody the one of his
opponents call who you fighting that
the guy he said i don't want to talk
you know what i get it bro i get it i
get you you know
when somebody does some [ __ ] like that
right now we're done with the boys
talking about logan paul i mean come on
no it's it's a paid you're a prize
fighter i don't know i'll fight him
but do you think he want to fight me no
no listen oh you'll kill him you're not
a prize fighter you're an entertainer
yeah you can't be a judgmental but oh
he's not good enough this is
entertainment
and this is when you're going to take a
check home you'll go to hit your bank
he's going to go to his bank
he's a rapper a world champions
back to back i deserve some easy money
but
the question is not gonna be easy he's
fighting [ __ ]
he's fighting now
he's already the greatest fighter to
ever live
he was just playing and he was fifty
pounds lighter he's my size
well he's the only that's why that's why
i thought that you would
might give him a good fight you know
make it easy
but but i don't mind but hey logan call
that [ __ ] excuse me call mr
logan's manager please
but it's still you know
listen you don't give me eight that's
too much of a risk this is what i know
you gotta be more what's that word when
you're um crazy
no you just gotta have more belief man
make [ __ ] happen
yeah you make your realities happen i
guess whatever's in your
mind you think what happened listen look
at that come see me
i would love i would love that but but i
don't i don't
mean he got the balls to fight he's
gonna fight you i don't think he's
stupid enough he's gonna fight you
not
no listen don't say that he is stupid
enough to do it
huh logan's got a good shot he just went
eight rounds with floyd yeah listen
confidence he might he might hate three
minute rounds
right listen how far the best guy is
blah blah blah
floyd got two that's what you know he
said well floyd fourth the best two
that's what he said
call it hey why did he come out to call
of duty main event by doing
and logan paul listen man that would be
so beautiful
if that could happen you got him yeah
so okay it's gonna go down
ellie how would you describe his uh
badou jack's career man this
this guy's encyclopedia mike this dude
knows everything but
by doing incredible because people
forget that he had a fight where
he didn't win he actually got stopped
and everybody wrote him off
you remember that yeah people said
you'll never fight against the
journeyman
yeah and then he came back with the
title i've been with him to china we've
been uh
ukraine and people love them all over
the world he has a huge father
very hopefully some of the greatest
fights of all time how would you
describe him if you were to describe in
a couple words man how
would it be as a fighter great
great fighter very quiet great person
too
so we're getting a lot out of them right
now mike yeah
what's your birthday birthday bro
halloween october 31st 1983
83 baby it was in the nationals [ __ ]
1783. so what's up are you gonna get
them on dude you uh don't
man normally you had people on the phone
within seconds
or you been drinking what's happening
i don't believe he was fighting but if
you think
he will i think he will i think he would
and i think it would be a very
entertaining fight
i think he would too well what would you
say why would you say
because he's in his early mid-twenties
he's got a lot to prove that
with ksi you were with ksi the guy that
you trained to beat him
but why would it be entertaining that's
what i'm saying because he's going to
continue because he's a big youtube
celebrity
he's going to come at you he's going to
come right at you he won't come at me he
is
coming
he couldn't do anything but hug him he
was tripping and he was hugging him yeah
but with you he's gonna i would
never let a small guy uh like
back me up why do you stop talking us
out of the fight i know
i think he's a bit i think he's a bit
offended because he's right i'm like
thinking dude how are you going to put
him against
he's going to kill him
yesterday it's a good fight it's a
possibility that he's going to go a few
rounds and he did really well in the
floyd fight so it's a possibility he can
go a couple of rounds with you but
exciting rounds
me and floyd is almost the same age too
soon
this could be if logan paul beats badou
jack he will be go down pond for pound
one of the best fighters
in the history of the world in the
history of the world you're talking
about who
oh no doubt about it be the great white
hope like a [ __ ]
he beats by dude and mind you the thing
is there's an animosity there
because you know badou was with ksi he
walked ksi out to their first fight and
he was in the camp with him now you like
he walked me to the ring i walked ksi to
the room did that fight
yeah but there's different like even in
boxing too like five pounds is a big
difference
yeah you know what i'm saying like yeah
five pounds and there was probably 50
pounds yeah
yeah for little guys five pounds is a
big deal but if anyone
you know he was holding floyd the whole
time floyd would have probably stopped
him
after floyd was gonna start with the
body punches the floyd stop
i thought well listen but know what i
noticed those little punches that he
flew it i know they hurt they don't look
like everybody
hurt because he's 50 pounds heavier you
have the thing does arm punches he
he got bigger like a weightless listen
arm pushes
with logan paul he's not a youtube guy
this is a guy that wrestled
four years in ohio which is one of the
toughest states for wrestling the
toughest
yeah you know what i'm saying like this
is this is this is this is
in football ohio yeah you know what i'm
saying so it's not like he's it's not
like fought this
real youtube disney kid like no he's
like dude
yeah was logan a disney guy also no no
but they they go with
i roll with youtube i'm with you i'm
gonna be disney now
didn't they go
what is your prediction if i fight him
listen all right listen you always say
it again
what is your prediction about fighting
and that's what he's asking me about i
said floyd's gonna knock you out [ __ ]
and i'm listen i think you'll knock him
out but then i said that about floyd
you never know mike one fight could
change everything and if i do it's
getting a little bit older so you never
know
yeah this guy moved around he got
something dude
he was like dreaming around very
and he had energy even though he was
tired he was moving never stopped moving
yeah i think the build up would be great
to it
because he's doing all the talking
you're too humble you just stay quiet
can i say something about that even even
being muslim you know the person that
made khabib
conor mcgregor oh yeah you know what i'm
saying that's actually the only fight
i've seen cinema cabin
but that's but that's exactly what i'm
saying right mike you find a villain man
he
you you be the person that you are you
need that villain
he knows promoting what i was gonna i
always play i guess who i am
you know i mean i'm the lovable villain
i'm humble but i don't think no [ __ ]
like i could talk i could and i wouldn't
but it's it's the exact same thing we
could even look at look at what could be
become he's become a mega star
man yeah you get somebody like that you
drop somebody that's a villain
yeah you know i'm nuts you know i don't
know i'm until something suck my
[ __ ] dick [ __ ]
you